hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Gotham episode 20 video if
you didn't know there's two more
episodes in the season we're that close
to the finale so there's next week and
then the week after that is the last
episode originally I'd actually thought
that this was gonna be the conclusion of
the ogre storyline but that's spilling
over into next week so it's gonna be
like a three-part storyline with his
character I feel like we were all in
agreement this week that the Riddler was
probably the redeeming quality of this
episode
he's consistently the most fun thing
about this show fingers crossed in
season two that they spend a little bit
more time in each episode with his
character they can do that they can
course-correct like that if one
character just becomes vastly more
popular than the others it doesn't
always happen because sometimes they've
already made the episode so it's too
late to change one of the good things
about Gotham right now though is is that
they've picked up for season two so they
have like another 22 episodes and they
haven't even started writing it yet so
they can look at the characters that the
audience has been rallying behind it
just spend more time developing those
characters so let's just go ahead and
get into it careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet
starting with top five moments number
five Barbara is captured by the ogre I
don't know if captures the right word
because she did go willingly that's kind
of his MO he just charms them into his
sex dungeon it's like 50 shades of
Gotham right now I couldn't remember but
I feel like the sex dungeon was actually
in the promos I feel like that that's
like a promo moment they would show off
there are only a few things that pass
through your mind when you see a shot
like that one you think fifty Shades of
Grey sex room or two you think of like
jigsaw with the Saw movies like classic
Texas Chainsaw Massacre type horror I
feel like the crazy torture would
actually be the preferable option
just because Fifty Shades of Grey was
such a terrible movie it'd be more fun
if they were going for outright comedy
but that's not what they're going
forward with the ogre storyline he's
meant to be like very threatening very
scary even though he's coming off more
like a Tim Burton villain you know one
that you laugh at there are a few
exceptions to that you know I feel like
Danny DeVito balanced the line between
funny and terrifying really really well
the ogre storyline is really the
backbone of this this theme that's been
crossing these I guess these three
episodes you could call them now people
killing to save those that they love
like you know is Gordon going to kill
the ogre to save Barbara even though
they're estranged short answer yes even
though you know we don't know if the
ogre is actually gonna die we could say
he'll probably commit to killing the
ogre to save Barbara
whether or not it actually ends up going
down that way comic book shows have a
way of saving villains like they find
some out so that they could always come
back in a future season but I'm really
hoping to see out of this Barbara ogre
storyline is like a dramatic character
shift in Barbara I haven't felt like her
character's been very interesting and I
feel like they could use this trauma
this ogre trauma to take the character
in a different direction and just have a
little bit more fun with her on to
number four
Bruce and selina go on a super special
date to try and do some super sleuthing
here's the thing about all that Bruce
and selina stuff this is a lot of fun
like I really like their moments
together but I feel like they work
better on a show say like the flash that
plays more on on light-hearted comedy i
feel like children just work better in
that context unless it's gonna be like
some crazy horror flick and that's not
really what gotham is the thing I really
like about Bruce and selina is that
Selina is probably the strongest female
character on the show and she's the
youngest which is just hilarious but
she's kind of the brains of their
operation you know even though Batman
becomes the world's greatest detective
she's the one that always knows what's
up I think she made her feelings for
Bruce pretty clear when she pushed out
for its friend out the window that was
kind of like her version of what's going
on with the ogre people crossing the
line to save people that they really
care about or love I don't think the
Catwoman loves Bruce like their
relationship isn't that intense yet
moving on to number three the penguin
versus Maroni so if you remember the
last episode he's working his way up to
just getting rid of Maroni but we also
have fish Mooney that's coming in from
left field to like we're moving into the
fact we're so close to the finale that
all of the mob elements of the show are
gonna turn on each other and just go
crazy in a battle royale I feel like the
show is just backing the penguin as the
protagonist of this storyline even
though he is one of the more notable
Batman villains I don't think of him as
an antagonist on the show like the show
wants you to root for him so that makes
him a protagonist
yes Jada Pinkett Smith did spoil you
know a few things that might be going
down in the finale so let's just not
mention them in the comments or if you
do just please use spoiler tags but I
feel like if you've been frustrated with
the penguin storyline you'll be really
happy with what goes down in the finale
like he'll get his really bloody
gruesome moment he's killed a lot of
people who this season argue Lee I think
it was a bigger WTF when we saw the
Riddler kill someone because he'd never
done it before once you do it the first
time each subsequent killing becomes
like lesson
WTF unless they're killing a character
that you love most of the people that
penguin is killed have been like
third-rate henchmen so it's not that big
a deal
and you could argue that but you know
Maroni was kind of trying to cozy up to
his mother so he's trying to kill
someone to protect a woman that he loves
just like the other characters in the
show with the exception of Bruce and
selina where you kind of flip the gender
roles on to number two
Barbara drinks a little bit of the ogre
kool-aid there's a certain part of me
that feels like she almost went into
that torture dungeon willingly so you
use wonder what's going through her mind
if you've been watching daredevil the
Vanessa character is like this really
complex interesting female character
that seems like she's evil but she's not
she enters into this really twisted
relationship with the main villain but
she doesn't canonize him they they have
a very loving relationship so you just
wonder what is going on inside her head
it's just fascinating to me
I feel like this grrrrrr storyline could
be a redemption for Barbara's character
I feel like there's a couple logical
ways that it could go down you could
play it straight Gordon saves her and
they jumpstart their relationship and
just you know try to deal with the
trauma that's like the safety option I
hope they don't go that route second
more interesting option is is that it
pushes her over the edge and she goes
super dark originally when they were
conceiving the show that the Barbara
Kean character was actually a different
character they changed it just a little
bit I think she was originally intended
to be something of like a proto Batgirl
like you know that might be where she'd
end up in like four or five seasons the
actors that they initially cast as that
character they ended up firing the
actress that you see is Barbara Kean
right now that's the person that they
brought on after the fact so I think
they changed her storyline I don't think
that this Barbara's gonna turn into
Batgirl or anything like that it's way
too soon even if they are gonna do that
usually what you see is is like a
character go through some crucible like
some really traumatic experience it
changes them and they find new purpose
that that's kind of what I'm hoping
happens with Barbara I'd really like to
see her go off the rails in season two
because of this experience this
experience drives her in like a more
Black Canary direction where she decides
to fight back would that not be so crazy
if Barbara went off and joined the
League of Assassins never gonna happen
but just you know like somebody on
tumblr can take care of that fanfic
moving on to my number one WTF moment
arguably the most
redeeming moment of the episode The
Riddler kills miss crinkles boyfriend in
the heat of passion I say it all the
time he's the most fun character on the
show I don't think that this is going to
drive him to villainy just yet
let's think about this he just killed
someone he is completely freaked out I
loved his reaction too oh dear
he has some of the best comedic timing
on the show like especially with the
watermelon if he tells Miss Kringle
there's only a couple ways that she
could react one most likely she'll
probably freak out and it drives him
away from the police station I feel like
there's a little too soon for that so he
might not tell her right away he'll
probably try to cover up the murder that
might give him the opportunity to grow
closer to Miss Kringle I do want I want
to see those characters together their
scenes are so much fun I would really
love to see her go dark you know some
sort of like Stockholm Syndrome where
she becomes like slightly evil character
and they entered it into this quasi
crazy Joker Harley Quinn relationship
the Riddler is just not quite ready to
be a villain yet like he's just not at
that point so I don't I don't think
that's gonna happen right away
what I'd really like to see is him you
know find some clever way to cover up
this murder and he'll find new
confidence in that so you know when he's
presented with a similar situation in
the future he won't hesitate to kill
someone it's like the slippery slope to
villainy like Hills just slowly find it
easier and easier to do what he wants
versus what's right I feel like we can't
call him a villain until the outright
starts committing crimes for pleasure
and leaving classic clues everybody keep
your eyes peeled Oh for clues with
respect to this specific killing here's
my big question for you guys though you
know he just killed this cop do you
think that he's going to leave a classic
Riddler clue as part of the cover-up
that he generates there have been so
many classic Riddler moments I feel like
they do they have to do that before the
season is over and this is like the
biggest thing that's happened to his
character so far also really fun Easter
Egg if you guys didn't notice that the
actor that was playing the ogres father
this old actor here
he was Moriarty on Star Trek The Next
Generation think about that that just I
feel like that's so appropriate to cast
him as this role here the father of this
really evil person
here's a really quick update on the
video scheduled for the next couple days
it's gonna be a little bit weird because
I'm catching a special screening of
Avengers age of Ultron tonight so my
flash video is gonna post a little bit
late so next I'm posting my flash video
that'll just post late tonight
be sure to
subscribe to get it then Tuesday morning
I'll post a non-spoilery Avengers age of
Ultron review don't worry I won't spoil
like an credits or earning the big stuff
like that it's just gonna be a lot of
fun you can follow me on Twitter and
Facebook for updates on videos after
that I have to figure out what I'm gonna
post agents of shield and arrow so I
might I might shuffle those videos
around a little bit too and then after
that I'll try to get through my
daredevil stuff there's just a few more
daredevil videos I need to post what I'm
gonna do with my spoilery Avengers age
of Ultron review it just wait till after
people in the United States see it
because that won't be till like after
May 1st
so after that I'll post like my Easter
Egg videos I'll do like you know full
spoilers stuff like that if you don't
know where my Twitter and Facebook are
there are links in the bottom of the
description for that so don't forget
really big episode of the flash tonight
while you guys wait for that you can
click here to catch up on all my flash
videos and you can click here to catch
up on all my Avengers Marvel videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you